[Music]  many months since stolen election in  america  it turned out that thousands of valid  votes were tragically counted  i am looking out on this diverse crowd  with every shade of white  all waving machine guns  i've never felt safer  [Applause]  what color face you want i want to be on  kelly  i don't make people darker than they are  this is called alexa this tiny woman  make a flirt on me  alexa who trap you in this tower  nobody want to put sex on me why would  they when you have dirty hair and you  smell  [Music]  in america women are equal to men they  have a brain like we have a brain  what these liberal snowflakes have crazy  ideas about women  a social distancing the reason melania  never stand  close to donald because she was doing  that before um kovid ever came out  if you think she's a witch please try to  contact me before burning her  oh okay she won't get burned  just keep going if you start you're  going to be in a violent situation  you